welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday we continue this half hour with
fears of a second wave of the
coronavirus
in europe there are now more than 21
million cases of coronavirus around the
world
it's resulted in more than 765 000
deaths so as covet cases climb in some
of europe's key holiday destinations
many travelers
are now finding themselves caught in
changing travel restrictions
mts tayam reports it was planes
trains and automobiles anything to get
back to britain
after the uk government imposed a
mandatory coronavirus quarantine
on anyone traveling from france we're
back in the uk
we made it the last minute decision to
take the nation off the list of exempt
countries
caused travel chaos i would have stayed
in france longer
but i i don't want to do the two weeks
quarantine
in germany which is reporting a
three-month high of over 1400 new
infections in 24 hours
mass testing at its main border
crossings
this woman is returning from holiday in
italy saying she decided to get tested
not only for fellow citizens but also
because it's safer to return to work
while in spain which has reported nearly
4 000 new cases a day for the past
seven days the government is closing
nightclubs and banning smoking in public
spaces student gabriel desano agrees
enclosed spaces pose a threat but that
nightlife in the streets
should remain an option
over in croatia and the party hasn't
stopped despite daily covid cases rising
and some neighboring nations tightening
travel measures to the country
the vital tourism sector is thriving
but as infections continue to surge
across the continent
national health agencies are saying it's
young people who are being hit the
hardest
forty percent of cases in france germany
spain the netherlands
and belgium are among twenty to thirty
nine-year-olds
prompting fears among experts that the
virus could soon spread
back to more vulnerable groups
but what to do about the economically
vulnerable
thousands of albanians who live and work
in greece race to the border after the
greek government announced tougher entry
requirements
to contain its surge in infections a new
normal it seems
that's anything but for cbs this morning
saturday
in this tab london